well this is very exciting for me how
surreal is it for you did you ever
imagine you guys be back 16 years later
reprising these roles no no no not not
when we quit but you know a couple of
years ago I started thinking yeah you
did maybe you did maybe what manifested
this maybe yeah maybe right
is this you
could take it it's actually fantastic
especially because for fans of the
original show it really brings back
memories for us as as an audience too
what was it like for you guys to step
back onto that set for the first time
it was just a lot of um and I think it
happened with everybody in the cat in
the old cat we call them the Legacy
calves it just it's like a lot of photos
a lot of memories you know just like
just so many memories you know it's
almost overwhelming a lot of Life
happened in those years yeah it was just
like going home I thought yeah that's
how I felt you know I mean and it talks
to me about like having Ashton and Mila
back on set this time as real life
husband and wife yeah as well isn't that
wild guess what I mean they are the most
beautiful couple I have ever seen in my
life even I was like
you know just gorgeous and lovely people
beautiful lovely people so back in the
day could you have predicted that those
two would find each other
no I couldn't have predicted it but at
the same time it just didn't surprise me
and I thought oh it was funny too but we
haven't talked about this with anyone
yet but Mila had had to find Jackie
again and it's so far away from who she
is now so it took her a couple runs
there to to get back into the Jackie
mode I mean what about you guys did you
have was it difficult stepping back into
Kitty and red no no like an old hat yeah
yeah
what was that it was like boom boom
there we are right back into it right oh
you guys have really good writers like
we do that uh you know that they know
how how the characters speak you know
and so it's it's pretty easy to slide
back into it oh and finally you guys
just uh got to reunite with Wilmer on
this red carpet and you actually shared
a few scenes with them in this what was
it like did you guys pick up right where
you left off oh yeah he's well he had us
in stitches because he had that accent
right away but but this character now is
unbelievable it's just unbelievable it's
like next level twists words like no one
else he had us in stitches he's one of
my scenes with Wilmer was my favorite
from the for the for the Run except for
the ones for the ones with me because of
course
[Music]